dans une vidéo précédente je vous avais
présenté la démarche des sciences
sociales
bien que cette vidéo soit très claire
elle ne permet pas toujours aux élèves
de bien comprendre chacune des élèves
dans cette vidéo je voudrais aujourd'hui
précisé des petits points d'attention
qui souvent pose problème aux élèves
souvent les élèves considèrent que
problématique se résume à un problème
en effet les élèves pensent qu'il y a un
problème qui doit être résolu comme le
harcèlement à l'école
il s'agit plutôt d'un problème théorique
par exemple la contradiction entre deux
explications ou tout simplement le
manque d'explications par rapport à un
fait social je préfère et je conseille
d'ailleurs aux élèves de plutôt
considérer la problématique comme un
moment où on va faire le point sur les
grandes façon de répondre à la question
de départ
la problématique c'est en fait les
grandes familles de réponse qu'on peut
apporter à la question de départ
dans le cas de l'échec scolaire on
pourrait définir une problématique plus
tôt liée à la motivation des élèves
tandis qu'une autre problématique serait
par exemple l'influencé du milieu social
sur la réussite de l'élève
[Musique]
le deuxième point qui pose généralement
problème c'est la confusion qu'il peut y
avoir entre l'exploration et
l'observation c'est à dire l'étape 2
et l'étape 5 il se peut en effet qu'on
fasse exactement les mêmes choses
lors de ces deux étapes c'est
l'observation à la ccl l'extorsion c'est
l'observation alors que l'exploration
permet de découvrir le fait social que
l'on souhaite étudier
l'observation est plutôt une
vérification des hypothèses
on est bien d'accord que parfois on va
faire exactement les mêmes choses lors
de l'exploration que lors de
l'observation par exemple faire des
entretiens avec les personnes ou même un
questionnaire mais tout ce que l'on fera
dans le cadre de l'exploration sera
beaucoup plus large
on posera vraiment aux personnes que
l'on rencontre des questions très
ouverte pour essayer d'avoir vraiment le
large éventail possible d' explication
du phénomène que l'on souhaite
travailler tandis que lors de
l'observation
les questions seront est très précise et
on ira vraiment rechercher les éléments
que l'on cherche vérifier finalement ce
qu'il dit ce qui différencie surtout
l'exploration et l'observation c'est les
finalités ainsi que la précision de ce
que l'on cherche
[Musique]
la conclusion est également une étape
qui pose problème pendant la conclusion
au conclu lors de la conclusion qui est
la dernière étape de la démarche
les élèves ne savent pas toujours ce
qu'ils doivent faire bien sûr ils ont
bien l'idée de ce qu'est une conclusion
mais ne peuvent pas toujours l'expliquer
la conclusion c'est vraiment le moment
où on va récapituler tous les grands
points de la recherche que l'on vient de
faire
ce sera aussi le moment de communiquer
vers l'extérieur les ces différents
points importants si l'on veut faire de
la science c'est dans la conclusion un
petit peu revenir sur les blocages que
l'on a pu avoir et les éléments dont on
n'est pas tout à fait satisfait par
exemple une méthode d'observation qui
étaient inappropriés ou un échantillon
non représentatif qui a été utilisé il
peut y avoir aussi des lacunes théorique
par exemple il ya toujours un point
qu'on n'a pas bien défini ou un concept
qui reste assez ambigu à la fin de la
recherche
eh bien tous ces éléments là vont être
mis dans la conclusion afin que un élève
ou un chercheur qui reprendrait la
recherche que l'on a fait est bien
puisse dépasser le cadre de cette
recherche et puisse aller plus loin par
rapport à l'étude du fait social
envisagé afin de permettre aux élèves de
bien comprendre cette démarche des
sciences sociales
j'ai créé un petit quizz l'aide qui est
un outil de flash car qui va vous
permettre de bien maîtriser chacune de
ces différentes étapes vous pourrez
avoir la vision de différentes cartes
sur laquelle d'un côté vous aurez le nom
de l'étape de la démarche et de l'autre
côté les activités qui sont liées à cet
état vous pouvez d'abord étudier ça de
manière totalement libre et peut
utiliser la fonctionnalité apprendre de
quiz l'être avant d'utiliser celle de
test qui vous permettra de vraiment
vérifier si vous maîtrisez cette
démarche des sciences sociales
je vous remercie pour votre attention et
je vous souhaite une bonne continuation
et une bonne étude des sciences sociales
à très bientôt
[Musique]